So, not one, not 100, but more than a thousand
prosecutors have had it
with Donald Trump and his attorney general
William Barr, and have signed a letter condemning
both of them over the Roger Stone case. And
of course, the letter is not going to actually
achieve anything, but it does tell us a lot
about the total failure of many of the systems
that we basically take for granted in our
country because no one has ever challenged
them or flouted them. The way that the Trump
administration has remember that Donald Trump,
uh, is, uh, connected to is an associate of
Roger Stone's or maybe better said Roger Stone
is an associate of Donald Trump's. Roger Stone
was indicted and he was convicted and prosecutors
recommended seven to nine years in prison
for Roger Stone. And Roger Stone, uh, of course,
has created this entire campaign to argue
how unfair everything is. Trump lost it on
Twitter. The justice department got involved
and very quickly the recommendation went from
being seven to nine years in prison time to
simply a recommendation for some prison time.
This led to multiple prosecutors saying, we
can't be involved in this resigning from the
case altogether, and remember that we're supposed
to have separation of powers and checks and
balances here in the United States. We're
supposed to have independence between agencies
and branches of government. It's sort of U
S government one Oh one a lot of us learn
this in seventh grade. The justice department
is separate from the administration. The president
gets to pick the attorney general who heads
the justice department, but the justice department
should be independently operating, investigating
wrongdoing, whoever it is that may have carried
it out, whether it's members of an administration
or not. The justice department should not
interfere or exert influence in individual
cases, especially for politically motivated
reasons such as the president doesn't like
the sentence that was recommended for his
associate Roger Stone. That's how things are
supposed to work.
But of course, the current form of the Republican
party is a shameless corrupt colluding organization
that functions more like a mob family than
a major political party. So Roger Stone gets
convicted for crimes. He committed in the
course of helping Donald Trump get elected.
Prosecutors look at the facts and they say,
based on the crimes, seven to nine years make
sense? And it does, and I'll get to that in
a second, but Trump catches wind of this and
tweets quote, this is a horrible and very
unfair situation. The real crimes were on
the other side as nothing happens to them,
cannot allow this miscarriage of justice.
Donald Trump has arguing that because people
on the other side politically who have not
been indicted nor charged nor tried nor convicted
of anything, they haven't gotten prison time
because this is the United States and people
who aren't indicted or convicted or tried
don't get prison time.
Stone shouldn't either. And then lo and behold,
the recommendation has changed from seven
to nine years to just some prison time and
now 1000 prosecutors, more than a thousand
actually are furious. Trump says, well, I
didn't tell the justice department to do this,
which is of course ridiculous. He doesn't
have to. The message gets to William Barr
and the justice department that Donald Trump
is not pleased. The idea that they are pushing
is that the sentence is out of whack with
the crimes that have been committed. But that's
not true. Let's go through it. Federal sentencing
guidelines, you know, sometimes you hear about
these wacky sentences that are way too light
for certain crimes. Uh, in, in local courts,
these federal sentencing guidelines are very
clear and they use a point system. Uh, Roger
Stone obstructed justice. That's 14 points.
There's an enhancement for threatening physical
injury to a person that gets Roger Stone.
Eight more points. That's 22, three points
for interference with the administration of
justice and other two points for extensive
planning of the crime. Significant premeditation,
two points for willfully obstructing or impeding
justice. That's 29 points. The fact that he
has not been previously convicted puts them
in criminal category one and the sentencing
guidelines table says 87 to 108 months. That's
seven to nine years. That's it. There's no
real justification for a lower sentence other
than political cronyism other than this is
a guy Trump's likes Trump likes, and in the
end it's likely going to be moot because remember
that Donald Trump can just pardon him anyway,
so do not let yourself be tricked into believing
that this is some unfair sentence being carried
out by some bias, the jury or an activist
judge. We'll get to those allegations a little
bit later. What is wrong and unfair is that
Donald Trump is getting involved.
What is wrong and unAmerican and unconstitutional
is that Donald Trump is arguing that because
his political enemies who have not been charged
with any crime aren't in prison. Roger Stone
shouldn't get seven to nine years and this
is just the tip of the iceberg. Donald Trump
has an enemies list that he wants the justice
department to go after. He has fired impeachment
witnesses. He's attacked before person of
the Roger Stone jury. He says he can intervene
in any case for any reason if he so pleases.
It's a disgustingly turn and that's what I
want to dig into next in more detail.